Hello, I'm Alex Villareal with VOA 60 America.
Today is June 27th and these are the headline stories.
President Obama took time during his visit to Dakar, Senegal...
...to comment on big news from back in the United States:...
...two Supreme Court rulings that pleased supporters of gay rights and same-sex marriage.
The president praised the rulings, saying they showed "we are all equal under the law."
During a training mission in Phoenix, Arizona,...
...two pilots safely ejected from their F-16 just before it crashed to the ground.
There is no word yet on what caused the crash,...
...but witnesses say they heard the engine sputter and pop moments before the jet went down.
A unique baby turtle has made its debut at the San Antonio Zoo.
The turtle, named Thelma and Louise, was born with two heads.
At one month old, zoo officials say she is able to swim and walk.
That's all for today, thanks for watching.